[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend Olaf
Scholz ist zurück in Deutschland als so
viel Drang nicht über sein Gespräch mit
Joe Biden nach außen öffentlich betont
wurde die Geschlossenheit bei der
weiteren Hilfe für die Ukraine bei einem
abnutzungskrieg wie er so brutal in den
Kämpfen und bachmut zu beobachten ist
wird es am Ende auch darauf ankommen wer
mehr Munition und Waffen hat ob die
Ukrainer bachmut jetzt aufgeben dazu
gibt es widersprüchliche Informationen
so oder so hätten die Russen für die
Eroberung dieser komplett zerstörten
Stadt über sieben Monate gebraucht und
geschätzt über 10.000 Soldaten verloren
in der hebestreitbericht
es wird um jeden Meter Boden gekämpft
die ukrainische Artillerie unterstützt
die Bodentruppen bei der Verteidigung
von bachmut neben regulären ukrainischen
Einheiten sind auch grenzschutztruppen
beteiligt Oberstleutnant osatschuk war
auch heute in der Stadt und schildert im
Videochat seine Eindrücke und
unterbrochene Artillerie Beschuss von
allen möglichen russischen Kaliber und
die Granaten explodieren überall die
wichtigsten Straßen
straßenkreuzentenplätze werden
beschlossen aber die russische
Infanterie ist Stetten geblieben noch an
den stadtränken im tieflug kommt der
Gegner an die Front
russlandsverteidigungsminister Scholl GU
persönlich inspiziert seine Truppen wenn
sie mit Orden einschwören nicht
nachzulassen in ihren Bemühungen
weiteres ukrainisches Territorium zu
erobern
es liegt noch viel Arbeit vor ihnen ich
hoffe sie werden weiterhin treu ihrem
Land dienen
viel Glück Erfolg und kommen sie heil
nach Hause
fast zeitgleich am anderen Ende der
Ukraine Besuch aus dem Westen in Lewis
trifft eu-parlamentspräsidentin Roberta
mit sola Präsident silensky sie nimmt
teil an einer internationalen Konferenz
bei der es um die Strafverfolgung
russische Aggressionen und
Kriegsverbrechen geht Torte Folter
Misshandlungen sexuelle Gewalt Russland
muss für diese schrecklichen Verbrechen
zur Verantwortung gezogen werden
Präsident selinski dringt auch auf Hilfe
für die Opfer
nicht nur die Täter müssen ermittelt und
bestraft werden auch die die misshandelt
wurden brauchen Hilfe um nach diesen
schrecklichen Erfahrungen zu einem
normalen Leben zurückkehren zu können
davon sind sie rund um bachmut noch weit
entfernt die ukrainischen Verteidiger
geben sich aber zuversichtlich dass ihre
Soldaten die Stadt halten können es wird
nicht ununterbrochen tagelang gekämpft
sondern schichtweise und deswegen sind
wir uns dessen sicher dass wir auch
genügend Munition dort haben und die
Zufahrtsstraßen funktionieren auch
das russische Militär will mit seinen
Bildern den Eindruck erwecken dass es in
bachmut für die Ukraine eigentlich
nichts mehr zu verteidigen gibt
was wenn China als Munition zum
Waffenlieferanten diesen Krieg Eintritt
die Befürchtung dass es dies bereits tut
wenn auch nicht offiziell gibt es ja
Washington hat bereits scharfe Warnungen
ausgesprochen der Westen hofft dass
Peking keine Wirtschaftssanktionen
riskieren will und eigentlich auch keine
Interesse daran hat die intensiven
Handelsbeziehungen mit Europa und den
USA zu gefährden nicht zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt an dem Chinas Wirtschaft
dringend einen Aufschwung braucht das
wird auch zentrales Thema beim morgen
beginnenden Nationalen Volkskongress die
Probleme sind allen Teilen sichtbar wie
Elisabeth Schmidt zeigt
ein Lehrer Lkw nach dem anderen
teilweise in drei Jahren abgestellt
Kilometer lang wir sind unterwegs beim
größten Containerhafen der Welt in
Chinas Wirtschaftsmetropole Shanghai und
treffen auch viele Arbeitslose Fahrer
eigentlich transportieren sie Container
es gibt kaum Aufträge früher gab es zwei
am Tag jetzt sind wir froh wenn wir
einen ergattern noch pulsierte Handel
bei weitem nicht wie vor der Pandemie am
Terminal stapeln sich leere Container
80% weniger Umschlag im Vergleich zu
vergangenem Jahr im ganzen Land sind die
Folgen von Chinas harter
nullkovic-politik sichtbar unfertige
Bauwerke der Immobiliensektor hoch
verschuldet
die Kaufkraft lahmt
und einige ausländische Firmen Sony und
Apple z.B haben bereits große Teile
ihrer Produktion in andere asiatische
Länder verlegt
wirtschaftlich in einer relativ
schwierigen Situation man kann durchaus
von einer Wirtschaftskrise sprechen ich
glaube dass die Regierung in Peking
sicher nicht zuletzt durch die
Demonstrationen die Ende letzten Jahres
stattfanden sehr nervös lassen China
unter Druck zwischen fünf und sechs
Prozent Wirtschaftswachstum wird die
Staatsführung wohl auf dem Nationalen
Volkskongress als Ziel für 2023
herausgeben doppelt so viel wie im
vergangenen Jahr
Unternehmerin Bettina schön will in
China bleiben Ihre Firma produziert
unter anderem für die Automobil und
Maschinenbauindustrie in China vor allem
das vergangene Jahr war hart sagt sie
china hat sich ja eigentlich durch diese
Null Politik wirklich für die letzten
drei Jahre so ein bisschen vom Rest der
Welt entkoppelt und wir wünschen uns
einfach dass der Fokus der Regierung
wieder mehr auf Reformen und Öffnung
geht das Themen wie fairer Marktzugang
Abbau von regulaturischen Hürden wieder
im Vordergrund stehen
Chinas Staatsführung hat die Mission
Vertrauen zurückgewinnen begonnen das
verordnete wirtschaftsziel soll in
diesem Jahr mit Wucht erreicht werden
und das hat auch Folgen für Europa diese
Störung von Lieferketten die wir nun
schon einige Jahre erlebt haben seit der
Corona Pandemie dürften weiter langsam
verschwinden das wird sich positiv für
alle beteiligten Länder auswirken
zugleich treibt es natürlich die
Nachfrage an insofern ist es in einer
Zeit wo wir uns eh schon Sorgen um
Inflation machen ein bisschen mit einer
Gefahr verbunden dass da gewisse Preise
vor allen Dingen im Energiebereich in
die Höhe getrieben werden die Wirtschaft
in der Volksrepublik wieder auf Kurs
bringen
es wird eine Mammutaufgabe für die neue
Regierung
nach Deutschland ist in der Koalition
die Stimmung schlecht hilft manchmal ein
Stuhlkreis in barocken anterieur Schloss
Meseberg im brandenburgischen den die ja
schon häufig für politische
Betriebsausflüge genannt
Kabinettsklausur man hockt kompakt
aufeinander kann sich nicht aus dem Weg
gehen und muss Ergebnisse liefern
streit-team gibt es bemerkenswert viele
dass die FDP dabei auffallend häufig in
der Rolle des nein sagers ist liegt auch
aber nicht nur daran dass ihr Chef
zugleich der Kassenwart am
Kabinettstisch ist eines der Themen um
die ab morgen besonders hart gerungen
werden dürfte die von Grünen und SPD
geförderte Kindergrundsicherung sein
Andreas
deutschland gehört zu den wohlhabendsten
Ländern der Welt trotzdem sind ein
Fünftel der Minderjährigen hier von
Armut betroffen darüber sind sich
Kinderschutzorganisationen staatliche
Stellen und das Statistische Bundesamt
einig viele Kinder sind arm populäre
Eltern arbeiten
etwa zwei Drittel aller Kinder die in
Armut leben leben bei Erwerbstätigen die
aber ein prekäres Einkommen haben das
nicht ausreicht um ihre ganze Familie zu
versorgen jedes Kind in Armut ist eins
zu viel das hat sich die Bundesregierung
erst in den Koalitionsvertrag und jetzt
in einen Gesetzentwurf geschrieben die
grüne Familienministerin hat ihn
erarbeitet ab 2025 soll die Kinder
Grundsicherung alle Leistungen also
Kindergeld Bürgergeld und
kinderzuschläge für einkommensschwache
bündeln 12 Milliarden Euro soll das
Ganze kosten doch plötzlich gibt's
Streit ums Geld die FDP und ihr
Finanzminister blockieren es geht darum
dass die Reihenfolge die falsche ist wir
müssen erstmal besprechen was wollen wir
eigentlich machen bevor wir seriös
überhaupt einen Preis benennen können
ich kenne bisher keine inhaltliche
Begründung für die 12 Milliarden per
Zeitungsinterview lässt die
Familienministerin wissen die Kinder
Grundsicherung ist das wichtigste
sozialpolitische Vorhaben dieser
Regierung daran wird sich Koalition
messen lassen müssen diese
Bundesregierung auch dieser
Finanzminister hat sehr viel Geld
ausgegeben auch im Rahmen der
Energiekrise und so weiter mit
Einmalzahlungen sehr gestreut auch sehr
reiche Menschen haben sehr viel bekommen
und ausgerechnet wenn es umarme Kinder
geht dann sagt er Stopp auch für die SPD
ist die Kindergrundsicherung ein muss
nicht verhandelbar man hofft auf ein
Einlenken der FDP für uns ist es wichtig
dass in der Koalition einigkeit herrscht
über diese über diese Projekte es geht
um die Modernisierung des Landes es geht
um den sozialen Zusammenhalt in
Deutschland sowohl in Meseberg als auch
bei Sitzungen des Koalitionsausschusses
da werden wir uns über diese Dinge
unterhalten und am Ende zu einer guten
Einigung kommen die Kinder
Grundsicherung ab morgen hat die
Bundesregierung ausreichend Zeit sich
mit dem Thema zu beschäftigen bei der
Klausurtagung hier auf Schloss Meseberg
in Iran Bank Eltern um Leib und Leben
ihrer Kindern vor allem wenn sie Töchter
haben Mädchen und junge Frauen haben die
Protestwelle angeführt viele von ihnen
wurden von den Scheren des Regimes
schwer verletzt oder gar getötet nun
kommt eine neue Angst hinzu quer durchs
Land leiden Schulmädchen an
Vergiftungserscheinungen betroffen sind
Mädchen Schulen in verschiedenen
Provinzen ihreranz viele Eltern trauen
sich schon nicht mehr die Kinder in die
Schule zu lassen Kamera 4 Jahren
berechtigt
mehrere Mädchen Ringen um Luft ihre
Mitschülerinnen leisten Erste Hilfe
Bilder aus Teheran heute
ähnliche Bilder aus der Provinz Farce im
Süden
die Mädchen leiden an Atemnot Schwindel
oder Übelkeit
Betroffene erzählen von zischenden
Geräuschen im Klassenzimmern und
Chlorgeruch
nach Gas dann wurde meiner Mitschülerin
schlecht und schwindlig
Klasse verlassen
die mysteriöse Vergiftungsfälle bei
Schulmädchen in Iran zieht weiter Kreise
inzwischen sind über 1000 Schülerinnen
an dutzenden Schulen betroffen
landesweit
Eltern und Angehörige sind fassungslos
und wütend ihre revolutionsgarten sagt
wieder isch schreien sie heute vor
dieser Schule in Tera anderswo mit ihm
der Zutritt zu den Schulen ihrer Kinder
verweigert inzwischen füllen sich
Krankenhausabteilungen mit verzweifenden
Angehörigen die Vereinten Nationen
fordern Aufklärung
wir haben verstörende Berichte über
giftige gas-attacken an iranischen
Schulen
dass diese Angelegenheit transparent
untersucht wird und dass die Täter zur
Rechenschaft gezogen werden
Aufklärung für die seit Monaten
auftretenden Vergiftungen versprochen
der Gesundheitsminister sagt er habe
extra ein Expertenteam aus Toxikologen
zusammengestellt denn immer noch steht
nicht fest welche Substanzen verwendet
wurden und wer für die Giftanschläge an
Schulen verantwortlich ist
ich glaube wir müssen wissen dass die
Reaktionen von Seiten des Regimes in
Sachen Aufarbeitung der Fälle wenig
glaubwürdig ist weil wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass in jeder Schule in Iran
ist Geheimdienst Mitarbeiter gibt
deswegen ist es sehr sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass all diese
vergiftungs-november schon wenn nicht
unter dem Radar des Regimes aufgetaucht
aufgetaucht sind und ich gehe davon aus
dass sehr viele Indizien darauf
hinweisen dass das Regime sogar direkt
involviert ist Bilder von heute zeigen
statt aufzuklären attackieren
Sicherheitsbeamte des Regimes Eltern und
Betroffene Schülerinnen die
vergiftungswelle sie wird die Proteste
in Iran weiter anfahren
und mit Iran geht es jetzt auch eine
Nachrichten erst mal weiter die
Internationale Atomenergiebehörde IAEA
hat mit Iran vereinbart dass die
Atomanlagen des Landes wieder genauer
überwacht werden können Hintergrund sind
Bedenken gegen Irans Atomprogramm
eia-chef grossy sprach heute in Teheran
mit Präsident 30 Jai experten hatten in
einer Anlage Spuren von Uran gefunden
mit einem Anreicherungsgrad knapp unter
der atomwaffentauglichkeit
Bundestagspräsident in Bars hat sich
empört gezeigt über eine Protestaktion
an einem Denkmal zum Grundgesetz die
Initiative letzte Generation
veröffentlichte ein Video das zeigt wie
in der Nähe des Bundestags die
Glaskultur Grundgesetz 49 mit einer
dunklen Flüssigkeit übergossen wird die
Gruppe kritisiert die Klimapolitik der
Regierung und die weitere Nutzung
fossiler Brennstoffe wie Erdöl
mit dem Schutz der Meere haben sich
heute zwei internationale Konferenzen
befasst bei der our Ocean Konferenz in
Panama wurden fast 20 Milliarden Dollar
zugesagt etwa für nachhaltige Fischerei
und Schutzgebiete und bei der UN in New
York sollen durch ein hochseeabkommen
die Meeresregionen geschützt werden die
außerhalb nationaler Hoheitsrechte
liegen
die Lottozahlen dieses samstags sie
lauten wie immer ohne Gewähr 1 7 8 21 45
48 Superzahl 0 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf Flotte Punkt zdf.de und
im ZDF Text auf Seite 556
und noch die Wetteraussichten morgen
gibt es ganz im Süden und im Nordosten
wolkenglücken an der Ostsee ist es sogar
sonnig von Niedersachsen bis Sachsen
gibt es Schnee und Schnee Regenschauer
bei 1 bis 7 Grad
das war's von uns mit dem Aktuellen
Sportstudio geht gleich weiter und
danach gegen 025 gibt es die nächste
heute Express bis morgen auf Wiedersehen
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]